[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's
cbs sports college hoops reporter
managing editor of college basketball
for the athletic
seth davis joining us on the program let
me start with the obvious question
who told you guys that you could dance
that we could dance or could dance well
those are two different things everybody
can dance
um i'll give you credit
for effort there so that's all i'm
asking for
truly that's all i'm asking for where
was the music
because that made it even more awkward
well i don't know you know you may have
seen there was a version on twitter that
didn't have music but when it was on the
air
we we did have music so i'll i'll send
you that one it was it was pretty oh no
no no i'm good you don't have to send it
to me
yeah you're good i'm sick i've seen
enough
i i only have one piece of advice for
peop for people if you're ever going to
dance
on national television and you're
worried about how you look while you're
dancing just do it near wally serbia
all right you'll be all right uh we're a
little punchy we're a little punchy
after
a thousand hours in the studio you've
been there since i have
yes i have worse loss of the weekend
oh i think it's rutgers um they had that
game in hand
and uh you know the missed shots down
the stretch missed free throws
um gosh there you know there are a lot
of them i mean what oral roberts was
able to do
um i guess maybe you'd have to say ohio
state as well the way that they lost it
i mean ohio state played about as poorly
as you can play
and still had a shot at the end to send
it into another overtime
and you know ohio state season
was just unbelievable i mean i think of
all teams in college basketball they
probably maximized
their potential as well as as anybody
and so for them to to lose a game or
they don't play
well um i just i'm crushed for these
for kids you know it's like the the the
pain of the tournament and how about
texas
um not only losing and losing the way
that they did and you know everything
that you know shaka smart has been
through being on the hot seat all the
time he still hasn't won a first round
game we had a shot of shaka
i don't even know if this aired dan but
it was after the game and he was
in the hallway my it's it felt like it
was outside the locker room or the
meeting room wherever they were and he
was just
standing there just trying to process
everything and he kind of knelt down and
closed his eyes as if he was gathering
his thoughts to go talk to his team i
mean
we think about the upsets and the
incredible cinderellas but there's
there's a flip side of that coin man
and that pain runs very very deep is
shaka smart safe at texas
oh yeah yeah again i mean i would hope
i would i would hope and maybe i'm a
little pollyanna so people understand
the capricious nature of the ncaa
tournament i mean this thing
is nuts i mean i'm so glad i don't have
to get on national television and pick
these games because um you know if you
did you'd probably look foolish all the
time
illinois that's a big loss too a lot of
people had illinois if you didn't have
gonzaga or baylor you probably had
illinois as maybe the team to win it all
what happened
loyola happened um you know over the
last
i'd say three three and a half weeks of
the season nobody was better than
illinois remember they went into
michigan
they beat michigan by 23 points at
michigan without iota sumu
and that was the first time i thought
wow this team really has championship
medal but
you know to me that the funnel sports
and especially the ncaa tournament then
is when you see
the contrast in styles and that's a big
reason why
upsets happen because you know team like
illinois yeah they're
they're capable of beating a half court
game but they want they want to get out
and go
but you know one of my rules of thumb is
if one team wants to run
and the other team wants to walk the
game's going to be a slow pace because
it's much easier
to take a team that wants to run and
slow a game down and muck it up
as opposed to speeding up a team like
loyola that is used to play in a certain
style doesn't turn the ball over
so you got to beat loyola their way i
mean i like them i like them to make the
final four for that reason
now porter moser turned down jobs the
last time around
st john's i believe but you got openings
here
indiana marquette utah minnesota
porter moser gonna stay at loyola it's
gonna be hard
it's gonna be hard this time around um
you know he came very very close to
taking the st
john's last time uh job um before it
went to mike anderson he told me a story
about how you know he went to st
john's and he got on the plane to get
back to chicago and thought he was going
to take the job
and he was still deciding so he took out
a pen and paper and he wrote out two
statements
to the loyola fanbase one saying i'm
going one's saying i'm staying
and then which one feels better and he
he thought that the one that he was
staying felt better so um
that's why he stayed but this time
around you got in you know between
indiana and minnesota marquette is
another uh landing place for him another
private school in the midwest
um it's gonna be very hard and and plus
you know he's losing
uh cameron crutwick and lucas williams
said his two best players as seniors so
um i think this time around he jumps but
stranger things that happened we said
that about mark few for a long long time
well we had brad stevens over the
weekend apparently you know somebody
reported that he was leaving he was
going to take the indiana job and i went
he's coaching the the boston celtics
he's not coaching the orlando magic or
sacramento i mean come on
yeah no no no no no brad stevens has not
taken
first of all he'd have to leave the team
now yeah i know
i mean you want to count the number of
reasons why brad st i don't know
you know my pal mark titus was was kind
of egging this on
on on twitter and i think he was having
fun with it i don't think he was serious
so
i don't know who actually quote reported
that but obviously nobody who
uh had any real information now well
brad shocked the world like you know
it's always possible but
i don't think it's possible we have a
bet i i'm the only one who said
the following rick pitino does not take
another job
in his coaching career seth i'm going to
have you on record
do you want to go with the dan ants or
you want to go with me well i don't know
who who did who did
i'll tell you what i think i don't know
who said what but everybody all of my
guys said that pitino is going to take
another job
oh you're right as usual as usual
uh you are you are correct i think rick
would have never left louisville
if um if that hadn't happened you know
what
if if anybody wants to hire rick they're
going to have to take their university
and physically move it to wingfoot
because that's rick's happy place okay
he's got a house on the golf course he's
got a membership at the club
and he's 68 years old and he's gonna
iowa's perfect for him he's gonna blow
that thing up because we're about to
have roster getting with
with transfers being allowed to change
schools without sitting out for a year
so when you talk about the mac you know
there's three or four good programs in
that league and everything else is a
fall off so he could make that kind of
an east coast version of gonzaga because
he'll have
if you give rick pitino just a little
bit of a talent differential over the
rest of the league obviously he's going
to blow it up look what he did this year
with it
they were off for 68 days because of
covid dan combined and he still got them
to the tournament
i said this last week to the den ends i
think pitino is one of the top five
coaches
in america i i just think that he he
understands the game
he can beat you with your team he can
beat you with his team he just has
innate ability to be able to do that i'm
not saying he's
the coach for every university or for
every fan base
but patino can coach we're talking to
seth davis cbs sports college
hoops reporter uh let the audience know
what to expect today since we do have
basketball coming up
in about three hours from now yes we do
well to me the game of the day
710 cbs lsu in michigan uh first of all
the big ten has not showed out i'm not a
big like conference guy
when it comes to the tournament but i
know it's obviously a big part of the
dialogue
um lsu is a really tough matchup for
michigan because i
i do think that lsu has found another
gear they're long
they're fast they're athletic and
they're committed to defending
uh and of course michigan is without
their second leading scorer now isaiah
livers
who is not only a really good scorer
three-point shooter he's one of their
best defenders he and franz wagner so
uh you know lsu's got three big time
scores uh in that one
and listen everybody's on notice i mean
oregon iowa oregon's obviously you know
tough to get a read on them because they
didn't play a first round game
um they've been up and down because of
pauses and injuries but they are at full
strength
and they can score the ball and that's
what iowa uh
likes to do as well and then you know
the nightcap is going to be interesting
to me
uh usc and kansas um usc has had a
terrific year they've got evan mobley
but
you know a lot of people go poor betting
against bill self in the ncaa tournament
so i like the jayhawks in that one
it's great to talk to you um by the way
that whole fbi
probe a couple years ago that was going
to blow up college basketball that
didn't blow up college basketball
right what what exactly happened or
didn't happen where
lsu and arizona and kansas and
it just kind of went away do you
remember do you remember having me on
when i wrote that tweet that i got
shredded for
so so it's parallel tracks first of all
the fbi track
where you had prosecutors in new york
and fbi folks
listening to low-level scam artists
trying to you know make a a fast buck
here and there saying oh i got this guy
i got that guy i got self i'm talking to
miller
and they thought they were telling the
truth so they thought hey let's move in
on this guy
and they're gonna he's gonna flip on the
guy he's talking to and guess what he
was full of it
the separate track is the ncaa which
um now has fresh evidence to uncover and
it it takes a while because they were
not allowed
to start investigating these cases until
all of the legal stuff was done they
told them hey you can't do anything
so they have to go back and re-enter
they can use the evidence from the trial
then they have to go back and
reinterview everybody and this stuff
takes a while
then you have the pandemic pushing
everything back so within the next year
to year and a half
we're going to see these decisions come
down but if you notice dan
they're gonna aside from will wade is
the only one who's like directly
implicated potentially
everything else like arizona sean miller
this is head coach control this is the
ncaa saying well you didn't do any of
this or we didn't catch you doing any of
this stuff but you are responsible for
what happened
so that's how they're going to penalize
these things and the last thing i'll say
about it is the
the most interesting one is the kansas
case because it's one thing for sean
miller to say your two
assistants broke these rules and
therefore you're responsible in the
kansas case it's like this guy from the
sneaker company
that you have a contract with did all
this stuff
and you are responsible because he is
technically classified as a booster
that's never been
done before so eventually it'll all
wrangle out but this whole thing about
you know all these head coaches are on
the line saying i'll pay him this amount
of money that's not where the action is
the action is in
agents and in this kind of underworld
and the head coaches
um you know for better or ill and
there's a lot of both is they're kind of
see no evil here no evil they know
what's going on they don't care they
just want the player
who's in the most trouble uh will wade
will wait because the he he's on now
again it's like
now he's lsu said coach lsu's head coach
i mean he's
he's on the line saying i made him a
strong ass offer
right and everyone's saying well we all
know what that means but i always go
back to
tom cruise's line in a few good men
don't tell me what i know
tell me what i can prove so when curtis
townsend of kansas says about zion
williamson says well we'll do whatever
we got to do to get here
oh i know what that means well what can
you prove that he did so
it's a much higher bar look all these
all these guys and you know what's
a shame frankly is that pitino was the
only one who lost his job and he's
was never implicated it was because of
everything else that had gone on at
louisville so it's all
shady it's always all sadie it is it's a
shady world and you're either in it
if you're gonna be a college basketball
coach you are in this world and there's
mud flying around everywhere and it's
going to get stuck on you that's what it
is
thank god for the games uh have fun
today thank you seth
and keep dancing okay keep doing this
and i love you okay and i love you thank
you buddy that's
a cbs sports college hoop analyst and
uh he's also managing editor of college
basketball for the athletic
and a part-time dancer